members of the u.s house of
representatives
interrupted their holiday break to
decide whether to give americans
two thousand dollars each in the midst
of the covet 19 pandemic
the bill is passed and without objection
the motion to reconsider is laid on the
table
the vote in favor came after u.s
president donald trump
finally signed into law on sunday a bill
giving americans
a one-time check for 600 dollars
even though he had said the amount
should be higher
i hope it will enjoy a strong bipartisan
support
the president of the united states has
put this forth as something
that he wants to see in terms and part
of his
signing the legislation yesterday i hope
that that will be
that view will be shared by the
republicans in the senate
but some republicans worried about
increasing the budget deficit
said 600 dollars per person is all the
government could afford
but looking at this bill today it makes
me feel like we're in the parliament of
afghanistan burundi yehman or bolivia
do we really think the way to improve
the quality of life for americans is to
just
print more money from the fed
if you look around we're going to be
printing another 400 billion dollars
the other business before congress
overturning trump's veto of the annual
military spending bill
something both democrats and republicans
agreed had to be done
as congress works to keep both ordinary
americans and
the military afloat the incoming
president is accusing donald trump
of interfering with national security
for political purposes
joe biden made the accusation after
meeting with his national security team
right now we just aren't getting all the
information that we need
for the ongoing outgoing from the
outgoing administration
in key national security areas it's
nothing short in my view of
irresponsibility
no comment from president trump just a
new campaign-style video he posted on
his twitter account
even though he's already lost the
election
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington